im spielfilm dem endzeit szenario wird
day after tomorrow patrick der golfstrom
und die folgen wind kappa verfahren
genau dieses szenario droht wahr zu
werden wenn der golfstrom sich
abschwächt würde in europa deutlich
kälter werden jetzt ein klick vom ganzen
fiction eine im fachmagazin science et
war veröffentlichte studie kann einem
angst und bange machen
forscher des klubs institute in san
diego haben sie erneut mit der bedeutung
des golfstroms für den klimawandel
auseinandergesetzt und dabei
erschreckendes festgestellt als sie den
salzgehalt des golfstroms im 24
jahrhundert simulierten stellten sie
fest dass dieser einen immensen
tiefpunkt erreichen und damit auch die
intensität seiner strömung um mehr als
die hälfte abnehmen
was hat jetzt aber der salzgehalt mit
der fluss geschwindigkeit des wassers zu
tun
der golfstrom beginnt im namensgebenden
golf von mexiko von dort aus lief das
warme wasser geworden und lässt uns hier
im norden noch ein paar grad wärmer da
auf dem weg zu uns steigt der salzgehalt
aufgrund der kondensation das zunehmend
salzhaltiger und kälter werdende wasser
taucht dann wortwörtlich wieder in die
entgegengesetzte richtung ab das salz
sorgt also neben den winden maßgeblich
für den wasseraustausch des golfstroms
ohne ausreichend salz wird dieser
kreislauf aber enorm erschwert die tat
eine sogenannte positive rückkopplung
bedeutet dass der golfstrom system einen
kipp punkt hat an dem es die stabilität
verliert und versiegt durch stefan
rahmstorf vom potsdam institut für
klimafolgenforschung und damit kommen
wir zum szenario de fünfte day after
tomorrow wer den film gesehen hat der
kennt die auswirkung des verwegenen
golfstrom und eisige kälte flut und eine
einzige endzeitstimmung schmelzwasser
könnte dem geringen salzgehalt des
golfstroms erklären die frage ist jetzt
nur welche zitat ob zusätzliches
schmelzwasser einen einfluss hat hängen
ganz erheblich davon ab ob es in die
gebiete kommt in den tiefen wasser
gebildet wird berichtet monika rhein von
der universität bremen um diese frage
klären zu können
nötigen die experten aber noch sehr viel
mehr berechnungen analysen und vor allem
einsatz denn ich zitiere noch einmal
ramsdorf nicht nur in der öffentlichkeit
auch in der gemeinde der klimaforscher
schien das thema nur von geringem
interesse
jetzt macht die ju studio für viele doch
statt sozusagen wieder auf es war
allerdings für die wenigen spezialist
wie wirklich zu gewinnen
zitat ende jetzt wird es wohl wichtig
sein müssen im fall eines falles was wir
nun wirklich nicht hoffen was würdet ihr
unternehmen
sollte eine solche umweltkatastrophe
eintreten wird die folgenden
wahrscheinlich vom ball zu spüren was
mir eure and strategien in den
kommentaren darf wenn euch das video
gefallen hat lacht auch gerne einen
daumen nach oben und ein kostenloses
aber dafür einfach hier klicken und
schaut das nächste spannende videos
dafür einfach hier klicken
sonst bleibt